voodoo lab
ん
goo
me
dare
re 品
car
teame
goo
なあ
ni
いいいいいいいいいいいいいいいい
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
ああああああ
goo
iroo
ああああああ
car
yeah yeah
nara
car
ありがとうございますもありがとうございます
皆さん
笑ってくださってありがとうございますが当然ご存知だと思いますが鹿児島弁で日本の
名曲
鹿児島弁に訳して歌っていました
私たちあり各3個とエミリーが平成を配置で前にしてこうやって活動しています淡河城
ずっと申しますみなさまよろしくお願います
今日はこう二人で大島紬作りにもあるんですが
大島紬お子を羽織って
鹿児島弁を
いろんな人に聴いてもらえたらなという気持ちで
1年前にあることをきっかけに
疑いようになりましたね
ハイあのあることというのは去年の元旦に奔走されました
全日本なまりうたトーナメントというテレビ番組なんですけれども
ご覧になった方いらっしゃいますかありがとうございます
あの何も知らされずに
その出演オーディションの前の日に明日
全国放送でテレビ番組の中歌番組の出演オーディションがあるから行ってみてくれない
かというふうに言われて
じゃあとりあえず時間まで知ってみようということで2人で行ったんですね
いざ現場に行ってみるとちょっとあの鹿児島店で何曲か歌ってくださいってやるかん
ですよ
いきなり
あはいそれから何曲か課題曲があって
じゃああのその時私たちが2人で唯一知ってる共通の曲が
槇原敬之さんのどんな時もだったので桃源時も
分煙時もうといった感じで2人で即興で鹿児島弁で
作って歌ったら2実5
ぜひ出演してくださいという連絡が来ましてそれでそれで放送されたのが去年の元旦に
でその時にやっぱり私たちそういう取り組み初めてだったのでまだちょっと若い世代な
ので
カラーの表示夏越しも見ぬふりその知ってる極光まあこういった感じで今のあみんの
待つわとかを知ってる曲を鹿児島弁
訳すと私たちのやっぱり何店ですかネイティブ language 日本語だけどまた
そっから掘り下げて鹿児島弁っていうところでなんか知らない安心感が出てきたんです
ね歌ってるうちに
まあそれからそれってあの番組のゲストの方達の前で披露した時にまあトーナメントな
ので小さいんが入って
でカップ
の方たちはまあその引きをしないように
東京都出身の方言がないカタチが審査員だったんですよ
そしたらやっぱり言葉がわからないんだけどなんだかすごく胸を打つものがありました
か
この芸が正直うらやましいと思った
いうふうに言われて
じゃあちょっと com 活動を続けてみるそうだね
私たちの再発見もありませんこんなに二人の声こいつがそう
鹿児島弁にマッチして言って二人のこれも合うしぞあこんなことってあるんだなって
思ってそれがきっかけでね結成してここまできませんその
ん
あの初めて出演した時は鹿児島らしい衣装を着たいということで東京の県人会の方にお
願いして土下座してあの東京の渋谷にもあのおはら祭りというのか
道玄坂おおあの歩行者天国にしてあるんですけどそこで使われているおはら節の遺書
にてそしてあの前回のて dx 桜島でもあのスピーカーでたんですけど
富山産って薩摩剣士隼人な監督がをされている方のあのキャラクターでコンコンといい
いるんですけどコンコン t シャツを着て私達は歌ったんですねそのコンコン t
シャツを着て面白可笑しい
チェック可愛く歌った時の記念写真をバッグに今気が
はいえーとピンクレディーの sos という曲を
鹿児島弁に訳して歌ってみたいと思いますどうぞお聞き下さい
me
goo
いいいいいいいいいい
よくシーラボ
ああああああ
t 4位いやぁぁぁ
wh
goo
al
whoo
ana
goo .ne.jp
ムーディーズ
ああああああ
goo
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
pal
he
pandan
ああああああ
dj koo ki o
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
he ん
ありがとうございありがとうございます
インクれリード sos をハイあの語源を sos の語源たどるとか取るとですね
早く来て助けてっていう意味合いがある素なので無理やりでしたけど腐敗を今回という
タイトルになりません
ねまあ私たち見たまんまなのかそうではないのかわかりませんが
鹿児島生まれ鹿児島育ちです
まあそうなんですけれどもありがたいことに10代の頃から東京に住んだり
海外留学をしてみたりとまあ鹿児島を離れて知らない土地で色んな経験を積んできまー
ますと一緒にフィリピンも入ったもはい行きましたね週間くらい
はいやっぱり何でもそうだと思うんですけれども
国境って近くに過ぎると大切さがわからなくなるんだなと思うんです
近くにありすぎでものってやっぱり投稿投稿女お咲を先を見ようって思うから
本当は足下に大切なものがあるはずなんだけれどもなかなかそこに気づかない
それって家族も一緒だなと私は思います
当たり前そこにあることが当たり前だから
暖かさや大切さがわからないそれでもいつでも帰って来ていいよって言ってくれるのは
お母さんとお父さんそしていつ帰ってきても同じ場所で待っていてくれるのはこの子
今日
籠します私は未だに
3日くらい鹿児島を離れて帰ってきて久しぶりに見る桜島で安心します3日ぐらいだけ
が暗いだけでも
ほど減ってきたなぁと気がします桜島を見どんどん下議員とか可能ですよね夏そして
今日は5月11日母の日ですね
a
お母さんとお父さんがこの鹿児島に梅田してくれたこの瞬間から私たちは未来へ向かっ
て歩いています
今から歌うたはそんな私たちが
tumugu 未来
そんな曲をお母さんのね本のおっかあの番場に包まれて
未来歩いていくそんな曲をまた鹿児島弁に訳してお送りしたいと思います
kiroro の未来へ
ああああああ
me
ほらそう
he
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
ああああああ
goo
me
は
の
ああああああ
goo
me
ee eee
wh
頬2
ああああああああああああ
bea
ああああああ
me
cookoo
wh
naoo
yeah yeah
あああーーはいいいい
goo
rar
car
ああああああああ
cookoo
ああああああ
cameroon
me
car
へいへい
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
car
me
goo
影響は5月11日さきほども言いましたが母の日
そんな日にこの場所でお母さんに向けてあ
私たちのお母さんたちも来ているのかな
っている見えるお母さんはビデオを撮るのに必死になっております
なんか運命に感じるなって思います
a お母さんというスクリーンにも出ていますけどあのスケール大きく言えば母なる
大地
鹿児島に私たちは生きているんだなと思って
a
ん
そうですね歴史あり文化食言語
すべて受け継がれて来て私たちの生活に鹿児島はすごく寄り添ってくれていますそして
私たちの母親も一人の人間として
あのーなんでも成長していくんだけど誰かのため家族のために自分の心を豊かにする
ために
日々
成長を努力してわたしたちに寄り添ってくれている
鹿児島って私たちのお母さんみたいな存在だなと思うんです
そして
伝統という言葉がありますけど伝統的管ちょっと古臭いのかな古くさいというか昔から
あるもので
形の変わっていないものと思われがちですがそれは
鹿児島が職を変え言語を変え
私たちに寄り添ってきた者たちを伝統的と言うんですがこの音島紬ま
伝統的工芸品そして私たちはこうやって口に走って喋っているのも
西郷さんのか腰の便から形を変え今の鉛になりました
私たちはこう言っていいんじゃないでしょうか伝統的言語
この鹿児島弁を
鹿児島人として誇りを持ちながら次の世代に伝えていけるように
鹿児島の余暇を後徐々に成長するように私たち持つヘッド
歌い続けていきたいなと入っ思っています
今日はどうもありがとうございありがとうございました
def
th
ん